the killing of two Palestinians during a
raid by Israeli forces has sparked
outrage in the occupied West Bank 16
other Palestinians were arrested
overnight raids were carried out in the
jalazone refugee camp north of Ramallah
Israel says its soldiers opened fire
after Palestinians tried to Ram them
with their car
ninja Ibrahim was at that refugee camp
just north of Ramallah
this is the street where the incident
took place Witnesses here tell us that
the Israeli forces shot at a car that
had three Palestinians killing two of
them and injuring the third many
Palestinians here say that this is
called an extrajudicial killing one of
the neighbor told us that he was waken
up by the sound of heavy shooting he
said that no ambulances were allowed in
before Israeli forces arrested the men
the marks on my car are from the men's
car they probably were scared to see the
soldiers maybe they couldn't control
their car the soldiers were too quick to
shoot
this is the morning house for the two
Palestinians the father of one of them
the father of Khaled told me that all
three of them were working together they
were coming home from work when they
were surprised and shocked to see the
Israeli forces many Palestinians here
say that there is an increase in
trigger-happy soldiers Israeli soldiers
killing Palestinians they say that so
long as there is no accountability these
killings will only continue we're
talking about
109 Palestinians who were killed in the
occupied West Bank by Israeli forces
including Al jazeera's Shirin abachne